[Music]  ah you please stop bothering like him so  Arthur I have some bad news for you this  is the last time we'll be meeting you  don't listen dear he just asked the same  questions every week how's your job are  you having any negative thoughts all I  have are negative thoughts  do my job  check out this guy when I was a little  boy and told people I was gonna be a  comedian everyone laughed at me well no  one's laughing now you can say that  again  [Music]  laughs ball is there  my whole life  if I even really existed  [Music]  but I do  people are starting to notice  I think this is funny  there's a joke to you  very one small thing yeah when you bring  me out can you introduce me as Joker  [Music]  the clown  [Music]